well let's go out live for once again to
Jerusalem I'm in Lisa correspondent
Alistair bunkel is is there for us and
Alice extraordinary uh evolving story
this uh quite recently Netanyahu
appeared to to be sticking to his guns
and uh the the Coalition he oversees
guns on this judicial uh reform but uh
but that reportedly is changing
overnight or orbit with no confirmation
yet
yeah I think that's a pretty good
summary I mean Benjamin Netanyahu
despite growing opposition within the
country has very firmly stuck to his
guns and said that he will push ahead
with these judicial reforms not just
push ahead with them but do so really at
PACE and the Hope was when he last uh
spoke publicly towards the end of last
week shortly before he left for London
The Hope was that well his Hope was that
he would push them through or some major
elements of them through before the uh
Passover recess in the coming days but
things have moved incredibly quickly
over the last 24 hours we saw his
defense minister yob Galant come out and
call for a halt in the legislation uh
Netanyahu decided to punish him by
removing him from office and that in
turn led to spontaneous Mass protests
across the country last night now
protesters are gathering again on the
streets of Israel today and there's been
significant developments across Israeli
Society bengurion airport the
International Airport here in Israel as
you mentioned has shut to outbound
flights and a lot of inbound
international flights are either turning
around or diverting
some major trade unions have said that
their workers will go out on strike
there's been a walk out among some in
the very revered high-tech industry here
in Israel universities have stopped
research and lectures for the time being
some major shopping malls have closed
their doors and perhaps of concern uh to
many people the 200 branches of
McDonald's restaurants in the countries
have also announced that they will close
as of about an hour ago so the pressure
is building on Benin Netanyahu the walls
are closing in we were told that he was
going to give a statement to the country
at around 10 30 this morning uh local
time so a couple of hours ago and we
expected him to announce a pause in the
legislative process that hasn't happened
and the Reckoning is that that is
because there's one or two figures in
his Coalition that are standing firm and
threatening to resign and potentially
threatening to bring down the government
if he does decide to pause this
legislation having said that it's hard
to see any other way forward for him
uh subuncle as always thanks so much